yuki takahashi journaliste indépendante
et militante antinucléaire
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france quel regard portez-vous sur cette
décision des autorités japonaises
alors c'est vraiment scandaleux parce
que ça fait effectivement depuis 2013
c'est tout radioactive pose problème
alors apparemment bellevue il en voulait
il voulait le des gouvernements étaient
probables et le résulté dans la mer mais
ils ont dit oui en fait d en créer un
un casque cross en ont les traits tout
va vraiment faire en sorte que ça soit
propre et caetera et puis on importe
comment on ne décidera pas tant qu'il
n'y a pas de consensus avec avec la
population notamment des pêcheurs et les
habitants de cosima et cetera or et la
population tout d'épaisseur en premier
protestent et maintenant c'est dans le
japon du mma à l'étranger et dont vous
avez la chine la corée du sud est qu au
lard des citoyens qui sont qui sont
alertés par par les japonais n'aiment
pas les citoyens japonais aussi
s'inquiètent de cette scène cette
pollution de qui va être à ajouter en
plus de radioactivité qui est en train
d'être émises tout les eurent encore par
les parages paraissent par la centrale
accidentée voilà donc c'est vraiment le
déni le déni de la démocratie ou dénis
enfin le dernier jeu de 2,2 delà de la
pollution de la et la dangerosité de la
radioactivité qui est une réalité voilà
et le déversement de ces eaux
contaminées commencera dans deux ans
malgré donc c'est de nombreuses
oppositions
est-ce qu'il vous semble possible entre
temps de faire reculer le gouvernement
japonais
et de quelle manière alors la cilicie a
vraiment une énorme pression populaire
et de et de la communauté internationale
oui il ya là oui je pense qu'il ya
encore la possibilité parce que vous
avez la mer les océans c'est un bien
commun pour l'humanité donc là ils
disent là il faut vraiment qu'ils de
passe quand en plus il ya des solutions
c'est à dire qu' il ya encore de la
place
ils disent que maintenant c'est plein
les les citernes sont pleines
mais on peut construire d'autres citerne
entre temps on va vraiment trouver parce
que vous savez ils disent après
traitement
ce traitement ne pouvait pas traiter le
tritium et qui on a quand même retrouvé
à dents longues
après traitement du strand sur nos
titres anciens qui est quand même très
dangereux et puits de carbone 14 qu'on
ne peut pas qu'on ne peut même pas
mesuré donc il y a encore des problèmes
technologiques technique et surtout il
est hors de question de les déverser
parce que le la comment dire la
concentration de tri surnom n'a rien à
voir
et les très très concentré par rapport à
parce que les centrales nucléaires les
biens des bears
effectivement c'est déjà un scandale
mais c'est encore des pollutions ajouté
c'est comme le plastique il ne faut plus
a ajouté la pollution dans l'océan
ça c est ça c'est la mobilisation
internationale qui pourra vraiment faire
pression sur le diapo et surtout les
pays nucléaires de nombreux japonais
aussi récemment manifesté contre cette
décision inquiète de voir leur pays
abîmé à la radioactivité est ce que la
catastrophe de fukushima a fait évoluer
l'opinion publique japonaise vis-à-vis
du nucléaire
oui oui tout à fait parce que il y a
toujours là la majorité des japonais qui
souhaite sortir du nucléaire
parce que vraiment la catastrophe de
fukushima on voit vraiment la souffrance
des vins des victimes et on voit que
l'état ne les aident pas ils ont enfin
c'est presque abandonnée quand ils ont
ils sont ils sont abandonnés à leur
souffrance
donc effectivement la majorité a choisi
rebonds ce qui est dommage si ce n'est
pas traduit dans dans la politique
à quel point ce que cette décision
décriée du gouvernement japonais
peut-elle abîmé ses relations avec les
pays voisins oui oui oui ça c'est un
problème passé depuis les 2013 oui ben
allal à l'erea chine la corée du sud sur
tout mais d'autres pays aussi on a eu
peur pour la contamination surtout des
produits de la mer et donc monde je
pense que déjà que d'autres sujets il ya
déjà des frictions et puis bon le
gouvernement japonais actuels et et on
peut qualifier d'extrême droite outre
nationaliste et qui donc qui dénigre pas
mon la chine est là l accord et les deux
corées donc je n'ai rien eu ça ne va pas
ça ne va pas arranger leur les relations
des bonnes relations dans cette partie
du pacifique ouais merci beaucoup
d'avoir prétendre agir sur notre antenne
et yuki et takahata je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste indépendante militante
antinucléaire